- I'm back with Kenan
Thompson, give it up!
(audience cheering)
In our world of Zoom meetings,
sometimes your friends see
what's behind you before you do,
so it's time to play,
What's Creepin' Up On Me.
♪ What's Creepin' Up On Me ♪
What?
Oh my God, Jessie!
Well, it's awesome and
I need it for my phone.
I want that to say every
time my phone rings.
(laughing)
Kenan and I each have screens behind us,
but we can't see what's
on our own screens.
So we'll give each other
clues about what's creepin' up
and if we can correctly
guess seven things in total
together in the time allowed.
the audience will win an awesome prize.
That's right.
All right, so you'll give me clues first.
Are you ready, Kenan?
- Yeah, I'm ready.
- Okay.
All right, here we go.
- Oh, oh there's a, there's a city
and there's a big, giant furry thing.
It's climbs on buildings
it's a furry thing
- Gorilla!
- that climbs--
- Godzilla!
- Yeah, no it's the other one.
- Neal.
- Swiping at the airplanes.
- Godzilla.
- No, it's two words, starts with a K.
- King Kong, King Kong!
- Yeah!
- Okay oh, this is if the
poisonous on the tail and
it's got little squeezers
in the front and then the little tail.
- A scorpion!
- Yes.
Oh, I'll get my milk from here.
- Cow.
- Give me some milk.
Yeah.
Ah, oh.
She's America's favorite sweetheart.
Probably one of your heroes.
She's a country singer.
- Dolly Parton!
I got that, I got that!
(cheering)
- She got that!
- Yes I did, sir.
All right, all right, all right.
Okay, so wait,
how many, how many did I get right?
I got four right?
We only have to get seven.
All right, all right.
That means Kenan,
Kenan needs three for the audience to win.
She is America's sweetheart.
Nicely done.
So I'm gonna give you clues now.
All right, are you ready?
- Yeah.
I'm ready.
- All right, let's do this.
Let's do this, ready and go.
Oh, ah, ah, ah, ah,
I want to suck your blood.
- Dracula.
- Yes!
Oh, these are at the zoo
and they're tall and they're pink
and they have they're birds
and they're, they're pink.
- Flamingo!.
- Yes!
- Flamingo, yes.
- Oh, this guy.
Oh, he said the wrong name is the pageant.
The wrong queen won.
He had a--
- Is it Harvey?
- Yes.
Oh, we already, we won!
(cheering)
- We won!
- Yeah!
We got seven correct 'cause we're awesome!
Body roll.
That means everybody's a winner,
get it Kenan.
Here's what you're gonna get audience,
Power XL simplifies every day life
with innovative solutions
for the kitchen and home.
Their eight in one air fryer grill
is the perfect countertop appliance
that lets you air fry, bake, grill
and more with little to no oil
and everyone in the house
seats is getting one.
(audience cheering)
(laughing)
Thank you so much for dropping by Kenan.
We love you here.
I'm so excited for you for your show.
Kenan airs Tuesdays on NBC, everybody
and you can see Kenan host
The Kid's Choice Awards
March 13th on Nickelodeon.